The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Settle down.
The weekend doesn't start
until after the lecture.
First we learn.
All right.
So couple of announcements, the
big one being the reminder
about that little celebration
next Wednesday, coverage
through the end of the lecture
on Monday, there'll be no
weekly quiz next Tuesday, and
Hilary wanted me to announce
that there's a job opening for
someone who's in class
anyways, and wants to-- if you
take decent notes and your
handwriting is legible, you want
to make $9 an hour, go
see Hilary.
All right.
Let's get into the lesson.
Got a lot to cover today.
Last day, we were looking at
the formation of molecular
orbitals by linear combination
of atomic orbitals into
molecular orbitals.
So we had our SLI six-letter
initialization, and we saw the
formation of sigma and pi
molecular orbitals.
And the way you distinguish
between sigma and pi is based
on electron distribution.
Specifically, in a sigma
molecular orbital, you have
continuous electron density
between the nuclei.
That is to say, no holiday.
So I've drawn a sigma orbital
here where I've taken two P
orbitals lying on their sides,
so they're bonding
longitudinally and when the
bond is formed, the one
nitrogen nucleus is here and the
other nitrogen nucleus is
here and you can see that
there's continuous electron
density, no holidays between
the two nuclei.
So this would be called
a sigma bond.
The pi molecular orbital, on
the other hand, has a nodal
plane containing both nuclei.
So since the nuclei are in a
nodal plane, that means that
you've got to have two lobes,
one above the plane and one
below the plane, and
that's shown here.
This is the example of nitrogen,
where it forms both
sigma and pi bonds and to form
the pi bonds, you take the
lateral smearing.
And so this is what
I call the 88.
If you take the 88, you're
going to make a pi bond.
So that's lateral smearing
of the p atomic orbitals.
And the last thing I want to
make sure that you appreciate
is that when you form multiple
bonds, you have to
have sigma and pi.
You can only form one sigma
bond because you have no
holidays between the two nuclei
so now you can't go and
invade that same space
with a second bond.
So that means you're going to
have to get beyond that zone
and that means you have
to go into pi.
So if we've got only
bond, it's a sigma.
If you've got two, it's
a sigma and a pi.
If it's three, it's a
sigma and two pis.
That's what we saw in the
case of nitrogen.
I didn't complete it here, but
there's two pi bonds because
this is a triple bond.
So there's a sigma and
there's two pi's.
One pi is shown here, and that's
vertical to the board,
and the other pi is the sigma
x, which would be orthogonal
coming in and out of the
plane of the board.
So those smear give us two of
these and then we've got the
sigma bond.
And we even extended this to
hybrid systems, and towards
the end of the lecture, we
looked at ethylene, and I just
wanted to come back to that for
a second because I raced
through it there.
And so we wanted to look at
C2H4, which is ethylene.
And in the case of C2H4, we
recognized that when we went
through the Lewis structure, we
had a molecule that looked
like this, and the thing to note
here is that we have a
double bond.
So once you see this double
bond, then that means I'm
going to need a mix
of sigma and pi.
Now earlier we had
studied methane--
methane, which was CH4, and to
get methane, we hybridize sp3.
sp3, which gave us four
identical struts coming off
the carbon.
Well, we recognized that
wouldn't work here because we
needed to make a sigma and a pi
so the gambit here was to
reserve a p orbital.
Reserve a p orbital.
Don't combine all of the
three p orbitals.
Combine only two of the p's and
that gave us sp2 plus a p.
And the box notation for
that looked like this.
Here's the p orbital that's
not been hybridized.
These are the sp2 orbitals that
are a mix of S, and I've
taken two of the p's
and I'm leaving
one of the p's unmixed.
And now I've got four electrons
to put in here and
that's where I ran out
of gas last day.
I have to put the fourth
electron in here.
These are still degenerate.
So now I've got still
the capability of
forming four bonds.
You can see-- whenever you
see carbon, there's an
interesting--
just something to train your
eye, if you see carbon in a
structure, you need four sticks
coming out of the
carbon, or else there's
a spelling error.
So look here.
This is carbon with
four hydrogens.
One, two, three, four.
This is carbon one,
two, three, four.
Here's a carbon one,
It's always got four struts.
That's not what's
different here.
It's the arrangement
of the struts.
These are all four going at 109
degrees in three space.
This one is going to have
three of them identical,
because we studied last day
the principle that equal
energies, equal bond
energies, imply--
I want to get the
spelling here.
Equal bond energies imply equal
spatial disposition.
Equal spatial disposition
of those bonds.
So if we have four bonds of
equal energy, we have the
tetrahedron.
If we have three bonds of equal
energy, how do I take
three sticks coming out of a
central carbon and make them
uniformly distributed
in space?
They're going to lie in a plane
and they're going to be
120 degrees apart.
That's the consequence of
having this structure.
All of this follow and why
did we get to this?
Octet.
So here we are.
Here's the three of them and
here the fourth bond is p, and
it's normal to the plane of the
board, and now we can take
one of these and bond it to
another one, bring them in
along here.
This is an sp2 and an
sp2 and they bond to
make a sigma bond.
How do I know?
Look, no holidays.
Continuous electron density.
And now in the plane normal to
the board, I have lateral
smearing, and I make a pi.
So I've got a sigma and a pi.
That gives me the double bond
and let me just show you the
cartoons here because we've
got some nice artistic
renderings.
So here we are.
This is the top view of the
three sp2's and then the p's
are vertical.
so we're going to move along the
z axis, bring two of these
together-- there's the smearing
of the sp2's on axis.
So this is a sigma bond, No
electron density holidays from
one nucleus to the other, and
now we're going to smear the
lobes of the p orbitals
of the unmixed carbon.
That gives us the double
bond and there we are.
This is the same thing
taken from your book.
This is the sigma orbital and
then chemists like to do this.
You see this sort
of slashed line?
It sort of indicates
it's receding.
It's going into the plane and
then these are coming out.
This hydrogen is coming out at
us and that other one's going
way, way in the back and this
is in the plane and there's
the lobes colored is they
irritate me always.
By the way, they've chosen to
make this the z-axis, which I
don't like.
The z-axis should be the axis
along which they bond.
And then here's acetylene.
Acetylene is a compound
that C2H2.
C2H2, and I'm not going to
go through this in class.
You can try it when you have
nothing else to do.
and so it's got a triple bond.
it's got a triple bond between
the carbons and then hydrogens
on either side.
Again, look at the carbon:
one, two, three, four.
But now we're going to have to
have two lateral smears, so
that means I'm only going to
take one of the p orbitals and
leave two in reserve.
so when I do that, I'm going to
end up with this, starting
with the box notation.
Here's carbon as it would
exist without any
hybridization.
An S and three p orbitals.
And what I want to do--
I want to have two pi's and a
sigma, so I'm going to just
capture one of these and reserve
two p's as unmixed, so
that will give me this.
This is one S and one p,
so this is called sp
hybridization.
And then I've got the two p's
unmixed, so now I've got one,
two, three, four.
are both orthogonal
to one another and
these two are what?
I've got two struts coming
off the carbon.
How do I get two struts coming
off a carbon symmetrically
disposed in space?
That's it.
So look at the shape
of the molecule.
You see it here.
There's the--
the sigma orbital is here and
then we have vertical and then
out on the plane.
And so you first would say,
wow, I understand that.
That looks a lot
like nitrogen.
And then, of course, I looked
at that, and I said, what
about the right-hand rule?
And according to the right-hand
rule, the z is
going in this direction.
It's a little more subtle, but
I pick up on stuff like that.
I can't help it.
OK.
So this is good.
So what I've done here is gone
through a number of instances
where we start with electronic
structure.
sometimes we hybridize,
sometimes we don't.
But what follows here?
When we start with the octet
rule and we start playing with
the energetics and forming the
orbitals, can you see that
there's a connection between
electronic structure, which
then dictates the bond
disposition in space, which
ultimately dictates the
architecture of the molecule?
Molecular architecture.
So there's a way of doing this
There's a way of doing this
systematically.
I just got ahead of myself.
Before we get to that, I wanted
to just pause here for
a second and reflect upon the
properties of the covalent
bond as contrasted to the
properties of the ionic bond.
So let me get to that first.
Properties of covalent bond.
OK.
The first property I want to
highlight is the fact that the
bond is saturated.
Remember when we said that the
ionic bond was saturated?
So what does it mean?
Saturated?
It means that there's
two atoms only.
Once you've got the electron
pair between the two atoms,
the bond is formed and that's
the end of the story, whereas
with ionic bonding, you can
keep by electrostatic
attraction piling on
and piling on.
So this is the concept
of saturation.
So we have the shared
electron pair.
Shared electron pair
and that's all
there is to the story.
The other thing about the
covalent bond is that it is
directional.
And so the bond spatial
arrangement--
these are the positioners.
You can't put atoms where there
are no bonds and since
the bonds have a direct spatial
arrangement, then
that's going to inform molecular
architecture.
Dictates molecular
So what I'd like to do next--
so for example, here's
one that we know.
You've seen this one.
This is methane.
This is sp3 hybridization.
So we learn that methane
is tetrahedronal.
We say that the four corners of
the hydrogen positions form
a tetrahedron.
So we call this molecule
tetrahedral.
So I could look at other
molecules that have sp3
hybridization.
So if I look at something like
titanium tetrachloride, which
we met earlier to make titanium,
this is titanium in
the center and the
four chlorines.
It's the same molecular shape.
If you see leaded gasoline,
the compound in unleaded
gasoline is tetraethyl lead.
Lead at the center, ethyl's
at the four corners of the
tetrahedron.
So all of these-- and
same over here.
This one here, sp2, this means
the molecule is planar.
The carbons and the hydrogens
lie in a plane.
The whole molecule lies in
the plane of the board.
If I give you any molecule
that's got sp3 hybridization
and has one, two, three, four,
five, six atoms, in other
words, all the bonds have atoms,
the molecular is going
to be a planar molecule with
this, the 120 degrees.
So we've got a grand scheme here
that allows us to codify
this behavior and the connection
between molecular
structure and the electronics
arrangement and it's written
up here under the term
Valence-Shell
Electron-Pair-Repulsion Model.
Let's write that down.
I'm going to go through
some examples.
Valence-Shell--
hyphenated--
Electron-Pair-Repulsion.
That's the model, and it goes by
the acronym VSEPR, which is
a five-letter acronym.
This is not an initialization
because chemists reverse
these, and they call it VSEPR,
because the V and the S is
kind of hard to pronounce unless
you have Slavic blood.
So it's called VSEPR, and that
is the scheme that's up here.
So I'm going to go through some
examples and show you how
you can start with electronic
structure and figure out what
the molecular architecture is.
So I'm going to follow this.
So first thing we're
going to do is
write the Lewis structure.
And the example I want to
start with is sulfur
hexafluoride.
I want to--
so the question is, what is the
molecular architecture of
sulfur hexafluoride?
Can we predict the shape?
And this is an interesting
molecule.
It's very dense.
It's about five times-- it's
a gas at room temperature.
It's about five times
the density of air.
It's got an atomic mass of about
150, and it's used in
the light metal industry.
It's used as a blanket gas for
casting of aluminum and
magnesium to keep the air away
from the liquid metal.
Otherwise, the metal
would oxidize.
But unfortunately, the sulfur
fluorine bond is a really good
infrared absorber, and when this
stuff leaks out, it's a
fantastic greenhouse
gas trapper.
It's got a greenhouse gas
coefficient that's, I don't
know, something like 10,000
times that of CO2.
So there's a lot
of conversation
about banning this.
If we ban this, we're going to
have to find a substitute.
There is no readily available
substitute.
And what that'll mean is the
cost of aluminum castings and
magnesium castings will go up,
which means that they won't be
used in automobiles.
Instead, cheaper steel will be
used in automobiles, which
means the mass of the automobile
will go up, fuel
economy will go down, tail pipe
emissions will go up and
greenhouse gas emissions
will go up.
So how do we get ourselves
out of this situation?
Do we ban SF6 or not?
How do you go about thinking
about that problem?
Well, if you're in Washington
today, it's the lobbyists with
the biggest bag of money
that comes in.
That's what's going
to dictate policy.
But if we lived in an ideal
world, we'd have people like
you who understand the chemistry
and what would be
the analysis?
You'd look at all the SF6
emitted from the cast shops in
a given year and compare that
to the increase in tail pipe
CO2 emissions if you replaced
the aluminum with steel, and
then you figure out what
the trade off is.
And maybe what you'd do is set
up a policy where you would
gradually phase this
out with--
heaven forbid--
solid research support to
give us what we need.
That way we get clean air
and everything else.
OK.
So that's what we would like.
Now let's look at the Lewis
structure of this thing
because that's the first thing
we're supposed to do
according to VSEPR.
So I'm going to put sulfur here
and I know sulfur's got--
it's 3s2 3p4.
So it's got six valence
electrons.
I'm going to put them
symmetrically around the
sulfur, and then I'm going
to bring in the fluorine.
I'll bring in one fluorine,
and I know it's got seven
valence electrons: one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven.
And the same thing with
the other fluorines.
So I'm going to put one, and
then for the electron pair,
I'm just going to draw a line.
OK.
You're smart.
You can figure that out.
That's just shorthand.
OK.
Here's another fluorine.
One, two, three.
So there's two, four,
six, seven.
There's one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven.
Beautiful.
OK.
So now what I want to
do is identify all
of the bonding orbitals.
So I see around the sulfur,
I've got one, two, three,
four, five, six, six bonding
orbitals, six bonding domains,
if you like.
Well, that's 12 electrons.
I said octet stability.
Looks like sulfur took that
idea and ran with it.
And it turns out that this does
happen on occasion in
elements that are very
electronegative.
Very, very strong non-metals
will form what is known as an
expanded octet.
And here we've got--
here's a list of elements.
[MICROPHONE ADJUSTMENT]
PROFESSOR: We need a
high-tech tie clip.
Pull out a little more, maybe
it's constrained.
It's tethered.
the bond is too tight.
That's what it is.
It's not flexible.
It's covalent, you see.
All right.
So here we are with the
elements, and the ones shown
in the in the grayish-blue
here are the ones that on
occasion might form
an expanded octet.
Not always, but if you do see 10
or 12 electrons around one
of those elements,
don't be alarmed.
If you see 10 or 12 electrons
around the potassium, that's
probably a mistake.
OK.
So we have six bonding domains
and what else do we have?
We have six bonding domains, and
we have zero non-bonding
domains, and in total, we have
six electron domains, in other
words, six electron
pair systems
around the central sulfur.
And on the basis of the total
of bonding and non-bonding,
this is what dictates the
skeletal structure.
In this case, the skeletal
structure is trivial.
It's the same as the atomic
structure because there are no
non-bonding domains.
And so I've got six of them.
They're equivalent.
So what's that going to mean
in terms of shape?
Well, I'll put the sulfur in the
center and I've got one,
two, three, four, five, six.
So two in one plane crossways
and then two vertical.
And then I put the fluorines--
one, two, three, four,
five, six.
So there's the molecular
architecture and it's termed
octahedral.
I know at first this throws you
because you see six struts.
Where do you get
the octahedral?
Well, if we connect the four
fluorines along with the
sulfur, they lie in a plane, and
if we were to pitch a tent
here, we could pitch a tent to
the upper fluorine, and we'd
end up with four faces.
So this is Greek.
Eight faces.
So there's four above
and four below.
I know it's sort of like a
Jasper Johns painting.
You say, octahedral.
You hear octa, you're thinking
eight and you're seeing six
fluorines or seven.
Anything but eight.
So this is anything but eight,
but it's eight faces.
Last thing-- let's look
at the energetics.
To hybridize like this, we
needed to do something
different because we know that
the base structure of sulfur
would be 3s2 3p4.
So this is 3s and this is 3p.
So that's 3s2, and then 3p4
would be one, two, three--
whoops!
I violated the polyexclusion
there.
OK.
There we go.
So I can't form six
bonds with this.
I only have two bonds.
So you say, well, okay,
let's make sp3.
Well, if I make sp3, sp3
will give me this.
So now I got one, two, three,
four, and then I'm going to
put five, six.
I'm still down with two bonds.
I need to have six unpaired
electrons.
So I've already consumed
my s's and my p's.
Where else can I go shopping
for orbitals?
I go to the orbital store
and the orbital
store is over here.
Here's 3d.
One, two, three, four.
So I've got one, two, three,
four, five d orbitals.
So what I'm going to do is, I'm
going to take the s, I'm
going to take all three of the p
and I'm going to lop off two
of the d's.
So now I'm going to have one,
two, three, four, five, six
and I'll leave three
d's by themselves
and here's now sp3d2.
And now I've got
six electrons--
one, two, three, four, five, six
and now I have six equal
energy states, which means
I have to have six struts
equally disposed in space and
everything makes sense.
All right.
Is this polar or nonpolar?
Is this molecule polar
or nonpolar?
Nonpolar, good.
Let's look at it carefully.
What do we have?
I've got sulfur fluorine.
Whenever you see fluorine,
that's the biggest electron
hog on the Periodic Table so you
know you're going to have
a dipole moment on the bond.
But I have six such
bonds and they're
symmetrically disposed in space.
All of the fluorines lie on the
surface of a sphere so the
center of local negative charge
is right on top of the
sulfur nucleus, which is where
the center of locally
positive charge is.
No electron displacement,
no net dipole moment.
OK.
This is working.
Let's try another one.
Let's see.
What do I have here?
I got bromide pentafluoride.
So start--
let's go back to the
VSPER rules.
There we go.
OK.
VSPER rules.
So I put bromine in the center
and it's got seven valence
electrons--
one, two, three, four,
five, six--
and I'll put the seventh
up here.
And I'm going to bring
in the fluorines--
one, two, three, four, five and
just as before, there's
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven.
So you get a bond with
each fluorine.
A bond with each fluorine.
All right.
So what do we have now?
How many electron domains?
One, two, three, four,
five, six.
Six electron domains as before,
but one of them's
nonbonding.
I get to use the colored
chalk again.
All right.
So this is one nonbonding
domain and
five bonding domains.
One, two, three, four, five.
One bond to each of the
fluorines, five bonding, and
the total is six electron
domains, so that means
octahedral structure.
The total number of
electron domains
dictates skeletal structure.
So man said put six.
So I put the bromine here,
and I go, one, two,
three, four, five, six.
That's the skeletal structure.
Those are the bonds and space.
Now I know one of those is
a nonbonding domain.
So where do I put it?
Well, they're all equivalent.
It doesn't make any
difference.
Nobody knows where the real
x is in this world.
So just for grins and chuckles,
I'll make--
I'll put the nonbonding
pair down here.
And then I put the fluorines
at the other struts.
And so now what's the shape
of the molecule?
You don't see these electrons.
And in fact, this is only done
by chemistry professors, the
other ones, not me.
I only do this to let you know
what the books are doing
because we all know that
those nonbonding
electrons are in here.
They're right up tucked
against the bromine.
So if you walked in the
room, what do you see?
The bromine and the four
fluorines lie in a plane, and
then you've got this
thing sticking up.
So the molecule is a pyramid
with a square base.
So it's called square
pyramidal.
And how about polar
or nonpolar?
Is there a net dipole moment?
Yes or no?
Yes, because we got the-- in
the plane with the bromine,
everything is centered, right?
The fluorines pull out,
but they all pull out
symmetrically, but
then there's the
fluorine pulling up.
So this is polar.
This is polar and it's got
a dipole setup like this.
Good.
All right.
Let's do one more.
I'm having so much fun.
I'm going to do as many as I can
until I run out of time.
This is the best part because
colored chalk.
That's the end.
All right.
Let's do this one.
Tetrafluoroiodate.
IF4 minus.
This is cool because it's got
a net charge, but it's a
covalent anion.
So same thing.
Lewis structure.
So we're going to put iodine
first. Iodine and it's just
like bromine.
It's got one, two, three,
four, five, six--
I'm going to put a seventh
electron here because I'm
anticipating.
Just to mix things up.
See, last time I put the
seventh electron up.
I could put the seventh electron
down, but it's got a
net charge.
How'd it get the net charge?
By accepting an electron.
So that electron's got
to be here, too.
So I'm going to indicates
that that extra
electron's here as well.
So iodine's got eight already.
So we're off to a
roaring start.
It's got eight and it hasn't
even started bonding yet.
So we know where we're
going here.
We're going to expanded
octet land.
All right.
So we need four more fluorine.
I'm going to put four
fluorines--
one, two, three, four--
and as before, so
we've got bonds.
One, two, three, four.
And we've still got some other
orbitals lying next to the
iodine and they bond
to nothing.
So we have two nonbonding, and
we have four bonding for a
total of six electron domains.
Again, octahedral structure.
Octahedral skeleton.
So I'm going to put
iodine here.
One, two, three, four,
five, six.
All right.
Now comes the part--
see, we said--
this VSPER consists
of valence-shell.
I've been doing a lot of
valence-shell thought here,
but I haven't said anything
about electron-pair repulsion.
Now I'm going to show you
how electron-pair
repulsion comes into play.
So I can put four fluorines
around here in
two different ways.
One way is to put the four
fluorines into play
and then I have the--
these are called lone pairs.
Why are they lone?
Because they don't
bond to a second.
So sometimes chemists call
these lone pairs.
They're all alone.
It's Friday and all alone.
So here they are.
So that's one way to put them,
but there's another way to put
them, and that's
this one here.
I'm going to go way over
to the other side, and
here's the other way.
The other way to put them is to
put the pairs in the same
plane next to each other,
because if I put the pairs
opposite each other,
that's equivalent.
It doesn't matter.
It just-- whether on the
x-axis or y-axis.
So if you think about this as
a globe, you think about the
molecule as a globe, so in this
case over there, I put
all the fluorines on the
equatorial position.
You can think of this plane at
the waistline as the equator.
So these are all at the
equatorial position, and the
electron pairs are
at the poles.
So the lone pairs are
at polar positions.
In this case, the lone
pairs are lying
in equatorial positions.
Now what do you know about
electrons when
they get close together?
They repel.
And it's a really strong
repulsion.
That's the Bourne exponent.
Electron-pair repulsion is
really strong and it'll jack
the energy way up.
So if you've got a choice of
putting electrons here close
together or here farther apart,
which one is going to
be the lower energy condition?
This, because this minimizes
electron-pair repulsion, and
in fact, this is the
one that's favored.
So by using valence-shell
thought, bonding, nonbonding
skeletal structure, and then
finally electron-pair
repulsion, you conclude that
this is the correct form, and
so you don't see these electron
pairs because we know
they're really tucked
in tight here.
What do you see if you
do a spectroscopic
analysis of this thing?
All five atoms lie in a plane.
So this molecule is planar.
It's planar, just as the sp2
ethylene was planar, but this
is planar for a different
reason.
Is this polar or nonpolar?
See, it's negative.
It's not negative.
If I were a cation, I'd
be drawn in like this.
So is it polar or nonpolar?
Where's the net displacement?
The fluorines are pulling away
from the iodine, but they're
pulling away symmetrically.
So there's no net
dipole moment.
It's cool, huh?
No net dipole moment, but
net negative charge.
I love it.
It just--
it's the best. OK.
So now let's look
at some others.
We've looked at CF4.
We know CF4.
CF4, you could do this
one in your head.
This would be just like
methane, right?
This would be tetrahedral.
I'm not even going to
write that out.
This tetrahedral and it would
be sp3 hybridization and we
just did IF4 minus.
See the stoichiometry.
It's four fluorines.
Four fluorines with something
and it's not the same
architecture.
So stoichiometry doesn't
dictate molecular
architecture.
Very important.
You can say, well, it's
a net charge.
A net charge doesn't
do-- it's this.
This is square planar.
Yeah, so I'm going
to add that.
It's not only planar, it's
planar and it's a square,
whereas the other one
is trigonal planar.
So this is square planar.
So I'm going to do another F4,
just to show you, make the
point that this thing
doesn't--
so I'm going to do sulfur
hexafluoride.
You say, gee, sulfur
I bet it's just like carbon
because carbon, sulfur--
no.
Let's look carefully.
So I'm going to put the sulfur
here and we're going to put--
how many electrons?
One, two, three, four,
five, six.
OK.
And then we're going to bring
in the fluorines, one, two,
three, four.
So each of the fluorines is
going to form a bond.
Do I have to do this?
Can I just do this?
Yeah, that's enough.
I'm not--
I'm raising--
we're accelerating now.
Now I'm going to stop talking
and I'll just think about it
and you'll get it.
All right.
So here we go.
Bonding domains.
One with the fluorine, two with
the fluorines, three with
the fluorine, four with the
fluorine and there's two
electrons, and they'll
just sit together in
a nonbonding domain.
So how many domains?
One, two, three, four, five.
Five electron domains.
Four bonding, one nonbonding
It all adds up.
Good.
But now I got to put
five struts.
This gives me the skeletal
structure.
As before, skeletal structure.
So I've got to--
how do I put five struts
around something
uniformly in space?
One, two and I'll put
three in the plane.
Three in the plane.
So three at the equator
and two at the poles.
That's the skeletal structure.
This is called a trigonal
bipyramid.
Because I can make a pyramid
above, right?
I got a tent with
three corners.
So that's a pyramid
with three faces.
So that's called trigonal.
It's trigonal--
three--
and then I've got it
above and below.
So that's trigonal bipyramid.
See, you're going to learn
all these new words.
When you go out tonight, you're
going to be able to
impress people to the point
they'll walk away from you.
All right.
So now let's start putting
the fluorines--
again, we've got choices here.
They're not equivalent.
So one possibility is to put the
lone pair at the equator
and then the fluorines go
here, and the other
possibility is to put the--
let's see.
I've got room up there.
The other possibility is--
let's make the trigonal
bipyramid--
is to put the lone pair at a
polar position and put all the
fluorines in the equatorial
plane.
And so now we have to think
about this for a second and
try to convince ourselves which
situation has greater
electron-pair repulsion.
So the way to think about it
is, in which position does
that lone pair come into more
contact than otherwise?
The other thing to know is--
I didn't say this earlier, but
it just occurred to me-- is
that if you've got a choice of
bonding electrons versus
nonbonding electrons,
nonbonding
electrons want more room.
Why?
Because they're not
tightly confined.
When you get something in a
bond, it's on axis between the
two atoms, and so things are
much more tightly confined.
So these things want
a lot of room.
So if I'm sitting here, I
interact with this fluorine
and this fluorine--
these two are far away.
If I'm here, I interact
with three fluorines.
So it turns out the equatorial
position is favored.
Give more space nonbonding--
place nonbonding domains at
equatorial positions in
trigonal bipyramid.
That's what number five means.
If somebody asked you to test
the microphone, instead of
saying number nine, number nine
or one, two, three, say,
place nonbonding domains at
equatorial positions and a
trigonal bipyramid.
And they'll ask you to step
away from the microphone.
OK.
So this structure here
is, in fact, the
shape of the molecule.
You don't see this.
And this molecule is called
seesaw, like a teeter totter.
You remember, when
you were kids.
You don't remember that.
OK.
So how about polar
versus nonpolar?
It's obvious.
If it's asymmetric and you've
got the fluorines and the
non-pair, this is definitely
polar.
And where's the net dipole?
Where's the negative side?
Well, along this axis, it's
pulled right to the center.
So along this axis, clearly the
fluorines are pulling so
you have something that
looks like this.
And how about the energetics?
How do we get five of these?
If we've got five struts, it
means we must have five
hybridized orbitals
of equal energy.
Well, we got six before and
before that, we had four.
Before that, we had three.
Well, now we're going
to get five.
So how do we make
five orbitals?
So in this case I start--
I want s, p, d, and
I want five.
So one plus three is four
plus one is five and
that gives me sp3d.
Gives me five and then,
what do we got?
One, two, three.
It's good.
OK.
Now--
so we've covered a lot.
All right.
So some parting comments.
We've been sticking other
things-- what we could do is
we could do this one.
We could take carbon and I'm
going to go now sp3.
only instead of putting
hydrogens, I'm going to put
carbons here.
So what happens now?
One, two, three, four.
I'll put another carbon here.
One, two, three, four,
et cetera.
So this is sp3, all carbon, and
this is called diamond.
This is called diamond sp3.
So these are all sigma
bonds, all sigma
bonds everywhere, sp3.
And these are very, very strong
bonds and these are
very tight bonds-- and one of
the properties of diamond is
that it has a very high
refractive index
because high energy--
and these are tight,
tight bonds.
So the electrons aren't
easily excited.
It's transparent, divisible
light, which means that when
light shines on this, there's
no expectation,
but there is bending.
So it's very, very high
refractive index and a high
refractive index is what makes
this such a troublesome
compound because it concentrates
light.
So you can imagine there's
somebody in a dimly lit cafe,
and she's sitting over in the
corner with a candle in front,
and she's wearing a diamond
stud, and it takes those few
candellas of energy.
It concentrates, it shoots
it in the room, and some
unsuspecting fellow gets hit
in the eye, is attracted to
the person wearing the earrings,
and that's when the
trouble begins.
So this is very, very dangerous,
very dangerous, and
it's a consequence of these
strong sigma bonds.
But there's another way.
There's another way that
we can bond carbon.
We can make sp2 hybrids.
So if we make sp2 hybrids,
that now looks like this.
The carbon lies in the plane,
120 degrees, which means we're
going to end up with something
that looks like this, et
cetera, et cetera.
And this is graphite.
This is graphite.
And now we have a mix of sigma
bonds in the plane that are
very strong.
In fact, they're every bit as
strong as these bonds, but
there's a fourth.
I said, you always
have to find four
struts off the carbons.
So where's the fourth strut?
It's the pi bond that comes
out of the board.
So there's a pi bond here and
a pi bond here and a pi bond
here and what we're going to
learn later is that these
things are delocalized.
Because of the spacing here, the
electrons can form a bond
here that then forms a bond
here, but it can actually
resonate in such a way that
the electrons can move
everywhere throughout the
crystal of graphite and this
is what gives graphite its
electrical conductivity,
whereas diamond is a
strict insulator.
So these are very strong bonds
in the plane, but not between
planes, which gives graphite
its lubricity.
It's a dry-lock lubricant
and so on.
OK.
So this is very good.
So we have a mix of sigma
and pi bonds.
And it's an absorber
and it's dark.
It's an absorber so it appears
black, whereas this diamond is
transparent to visible light.
And if you look in your book,
this is all categorized for
you, everything that we've
done here with VSPER.
All right.
Look at this.
All nice big system.
OK.
So here's diamond, which I was
trying to draw over here, four
struts sp3 hybridized.
this is graphite sp2, and these
are pi bonds in between.
OK.
Now suppose this fellow asks
this girl out, and things get
serious and they get--
I'm going to use an adverb
here-- really serious and he
decides maybe he wants to make
a commitment and he wants to
buy her a ring, an engagement
ring, and the custom is that
the engagement ring
has a stone in it.
Now being an MIT student, he
knows that he wants to have
symbolism in that stone.
Now the custom is to get
diamond, but it turns out that
if you look carefully, the
stable form of carbon at room
temperature and atmospheric
pressure is not
diamond, it's graphite.
So if he wants to give his
love this stone that
symbolizes eternal commitment,
wouldn't he choose the stable
form and not the one that's
metastable and doesn't
represent the natural state
at room temperature?
That's the truth.
Graphite is the stable form.
I leave it up to the young man
to persuade the young lady
that the gemstone is going
to have graphite
in it and not diamond.
OK.
Now something very interesting
happened.
What I wanted to play for you as
you're leaving today is an
old Beatles song, Lucy in
the Sky With Diamonds.
And what happened--
before I get to it, what
happened was-- and this is
even in today's Le Tech if you
look on the second page, "New
Fossil Skeleton from africa
Predates Lucy." It was just
discovered.
I'm not kidding you.
This isn't a joke.
I heard this on NPR
last night.
So it's a female skeleton of a
pre-hominid, 4.4 million years
old, which is a million
years older than Lucy.
Lucy was discovered in
Ethiopia in 1974 and
considered to be 3.18
million years old.
This new one is 4.4 million
years old, about four feet
tall, and it just turns the
clock even farther back.
The interesting thing
is the name.
How did the skeleton
discovered in 1974
get the name Lucy?
Interesting story.
There were two American
archaeologists that were head
of the team that did the dig,
and they were so excited the
night they found this
pre-hominid skeleton.
They knew it was a female, and
they hadn't dated it yet, but
they knew that it was roughly
way, way back, but it was
definitely female.
So they were back at the
campfire, kicking back,
drinking, probably heavily, and
singing songs, and one of
the songs they were singing
was Lucy in the Sky With
Diamonds and that night, they
named the skeleton Lucy.
But the story doesn't
end there.
Where did this Lucy in the Sky
With Diamonds come from?
John Lennon, one of the--
you may have heard of this group
or not, but there was
this group called The Beatles.
So one of the lead composers
was John Lennon.
His six-year-old son came home
from school one day with a
piece of artwork, and the father
asks, what is this?
He says, it's a painting of my
classmate Lucy, and it was
Lucy and he had diamonds
in the sky.
So it was Lucy in the Sky with
Diamonds, and then they wrote
the song about it.
The real Lucy just
died this week.
She had Lupus.
She died at the age of 46.
And all of these things have
come together just because we
had this lesson today about
covalent bonding, which took
us to this, which then took us
to Ethiopia, which then takes
this up here.
and so with that, I think
we'll go for an early
dismissal, and I'll wish
you a pleasant weekend.